hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown Memorial Day
weekend will look a lot different this
year as venues across the nation reopen
with health and safety measures in place
but the holiday that usually brings the
country together appears to be dividing
it when it comes to kovat 19
restrictions Fox News Sunday host Chris
Wallace joins host Chris foster to
discuss this political fight and the
2020 presidential race also country star
and Fox Nation host John Rich joins host
Dave Anthony to discuss reopening his
Nashville bar and restaurant and why he
says he is not requiring customers to
wear face masks Plus commentary from
co-host of Fox & Friends and the host of
the Brian Kilmeade show Brian kill me
the Fox News rundown is a Daily News
podcast where we take a deeper look at
the stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to Fox News podcast.com
Abbey hornacek this is Tucker Carlson
and I'm Jessica Tarlov this is the Fox
News rundown
Friday May 22nd 2020 I'm Chris Foster
for some Americans wearing a face mask
in public or not it's a political
statement Fox News Sunday host Chris
Wallace says maybe that's a sign that
it's beginning to lift a little is that
you're saying more politics I'm Dave
Anthony country star John Rich can't
tour in this Corona crisis but his
nashville restaurant is back open and
he's not doing what some are getting
customer info for contact tracing if
anyone gets sick no and nobody's gonna
contact tracing me either by the way and
I do think right now we're seeing
examples of certain states certain
cities going to such degrees that I
would call it bordering on communism and
I'm Brian Kilmeade I've got the final
word on the Fox News rundown
the latest Fox News poll has Joe Biden
leading President Trump in the race for
president by eight points 17% more
voters say they trust Biden on health
care nine percent more say he'll do a
better job on coronavirus six percent on
handling relations with China the
President does have a three percent edge
on who will do better for the economy
Joe Biden this week tells the graduating
class of Columbia Law School the very
people tasked with enforcing the rule of
law or abusing their powers protecting
their friends weakening the very
principles that make our country work
and he's debuted a nickname for the man
in the White House President Tweety
president Trump has been keeping his
attacks up on sleepy Joe and his old
boss Barack Obama look he was an
incompetent president that's all I can
say grossly incompetent and about those
polls showing Biden ahead it's a very
close race and this thing is gonna go a
bunch of different ways I think the the
Biden probably is ahead although in some
swing states he seems to be behind but I
done of this matters now because you
know his poll was just a snapshot Chris
Wallace is the host of Fox News Sunday
you know what's really gonna decide this
I think two things one what's the state
of the virus and the economy going to be
in October of 2020 it you know it
doesn't have to be all back to February
but you know are are people going to
have a sense that the virus is getting
under control that the curb is down not
up there hasn't been a second spike and
especially where are we on the medical
front in terms of vaccines or effective
treatments cures and and and the
economic side again doesn't have to be
back to you know 29,000 and the Dow but
are we getting out of the depths of this
deep recession or not that's that's the
point one point two is Joe Biden and you
know I understand being careful but I do
think that he's got to get out I think
just staying locked up in your basement
you know there there are ways you see a
lot of Americans who are out maybe with
mass maybe social distance you know I
don't understand for instance why he's
in Delaware near Philadelphia why he
can't go and hold one of those
roundtables like the president holds
where everybody's 6 or 8 feet away from
each other without mass and they were
all talking about about issues you get
old a news conference on his front lawn
in you know and be 10 feet away from
people but I just think it's a it's
becoming an increasingly bad look as
people are beginning to open up for him
to be stalked in the basement of his of
his home in Delaware and and that gets
me to my second point
there's it's gonna be a choice at some
point is one that's a referendum on on
the president and how he's handling the
virus and the economy but too it's also
always gonna be a choice well whenever I
think I am what do I prefer Biden and
Biden has got to make a better fight
event and a bigger you know a bigger
portion than he is right now yeah I
don't know that he really gets to just
keep his head down until what the
debates start I mean you're right over
the last time I saw him and in person or
added in a public event no I mean you
know you see him in these in in his home
you know but it's don't listen to white
oh so it's just simply it's not I have
not seen Jill Biden on a picture without
a split screen you know in real life
with another person and you can't run
for president that way and I understand
social distancing I understand his age
and that he's in a vulnerable group but
you got to find a way around it and and
come out you know from from what seems
almost to be hiding yeah specially when
you contrasted with President Trump who
has made a few public appearances and
when he does he's making a point of of
not wearing a mask which is something
that among other things with this virus
outbreak has become politicized now get
a couple friends in other countries who
are watching what's going on over here
and they're like everybody there we're
in where they are is pretty much on
board with a mix of personal
responsibility and government guidelines
but here wearing a mask to a lot of
people is an affront to their freedom
yeah I don't get that you know and I
think we may have talked about this
before but you know personal freedom I'm
all for personal freedom and it's part
of the Constitution but your personal
freedom
and at the point that you endanger me
and you know it the best way it was once
put as the your personal freedom ends at
your fist or you know extends to your
fist and ends when your fist is at the
point of my chin so you know and I just
it just seemed so aggressively reckless
the idea that people would go into you
know when do we see you all seeing these
pictures of people in a target or a
Walmart or something where they're
saying everybody wear a mask and you
know you're not wearing a mask to
protect yourself you're wearing a mask
to prevent you from transmitting it to
other people so basically when you don't
wear a mask
you're not endangering yourself you're
endangering everybody around you and why
somebody would find that somehow
threatening to their personal freedom I
think is curious yeah and of course on
the other hand there's some stay-at-home
people who think that anybody who wants
to go out just don't care
Amma's dying on top of the actual
effects the virus it's all that is
personally bumming me out
it's all I wanted to say what back at
home no not that being stuck at home the
fact that while I'm stuck at home
everybody is having these fights and
politicizing the whole thing as though I
and and you know maybe that maybe that's
a sign that it's beginning to lift a
little is that your saying more politics
and you know and it's following the
predictable lines you know the right
wanted more on personal freedom more
important in the envelope the left more
on on observing the guidelines and and
and sheltering in place and you're also
seeing in Washington where you know in
the beginning when it was just so scary
and both economically and and in terms
of health where they were just passing
these trillion dollar bills without any
regard and now we're saying you know the
Democrats passed a bill in the house
that they know has no chance the
Republicans saying well let's wait to
June and I just wish I'm not saying it
was right or wrong I just wish that you
know we could have stopped playing
politics and and on all of this stuff
and go back to what's best for the
country and again follow the science
follow
the facts you can't spin a virus it you
know it's a natural phenomenon and
people seem to forget it's like a
hurricane it's like an earthquake it's
gonna it's gonna just happen and you
can't you know your opinion doesn't
matter
sometimes play these little mind games
sometimes what would what would be
happening in this exact same
circumstance if President if it was
president Hillary Clinton or if it was
President Obama I wonder if Barack Obama
would be wearing masks at these visits
to plants oh absolutely
no I don't think there's any question I
think you know look I understand a
president any president not wanting when
he suggested the country to wear a mask
and you know if he's going to make a
speech at a news conference to do it to
a mass seems to me to be foolish and I
think that that and I do think there's a
right and wrong in this particular case
I do think that our leaders ought to be
modeling responsible behavior and and
you know they ought to be would think
because the way they act is going to be
particularly their supporters is going
to be followed by them and modeled by
the man I'd just seems to me I don't
think there's any question that Barack
Obama if he were going to a plant and
everybody else were wearing a mask
Ede wear a mask now maybe he'd set
himself up on a podium at the end and
they'd go off the mask and talk but I
don't think he'd be three four or five
feet away from people and not wearing a
mask and frankly I think it's a mistake
on the part of the president and as long
as we're on the subject
hydroxychloroquine I mean my gosh you
know the the president just very
blithely said he took it as a preventive
not as a cure for a disease and you know
again the did the FDA has put out
regulations saying the Dolan should be
used in a hospital setting and only for
people who were very sick you know I in
the end I don't really care if the
president decides he wants to use it
because if that's the choice he wants to
make okay but I've what worries me is
there a lot of people who like this
president we're going to follow that
behavior who don't have doctors on you
know seeing them 24/7 who aren't getting
tests every day and it strikes me as as
reckless
coming from Memorial Day weekend are you
in sort of wait-and-see mode as far as
summer vacations go or you do actually
have plans you looking forward to
getting out there it's sort of a muted
way to start the summer well you know
we've been fortunate enough and I and I
you know when I talk about what people
should do I understand I am really lucky
I assume you're really lucky we are able
to do what we do at home we don't have
to go into an office we don't have to
you know take mass transit and my job
doesn't and my lively that doesn't
depend on it so I understand the very
privileged and what the unfortunate
position I'm in I'm not going to sit
there and tell people who don't have all
those advantages but we have a house in
you know out near Chesapeake Bay in
Annapolis and you know I'm just
sheltering in place here I'm not going
to travel anyplace not going to get on a
plane it's a very pleasant place to be I
wish I didn't have to be here that it
wasn't under these circumstances but
frankly my summer people were saying
well I'm gonna take a week off I'm just
gonna keep doing my show keep doing my
reporting and you know frankly it keeps
me saying yeah you and me both buddy
Chris Wallace host of Fox News Sunday
always a pleasure I'll talk to you soon
you bet thank you Chris Dave site
[Music]
this is brian kilmeade with your fox
news commentary coming up by now every
state has lifted some coronavirus
restrictions even michigan or people
have protested stay at home orders well
we don't want to do is simply drop all
of our Guard governor Gretchen Whitmer a
Democrat is now allowing gatherings of
up to ten people next week
stores can open in Michigan V
appointments life has changed it's
important that we change along with it
so we can safely get back to some
normalcy other states are being more
lenient and reopening like Texas where
Republican governor Greg Abbott says
people need to get back to work to open
your businesses to pay your bills to put
food on your tables
speaking of tables more States or
letting restaurants reopen like
Connecticut though only for outside
dining in that state for now I think
people are excited to get out and maybe
you know have that special birthday that
they missed our anniversary and I think
people they want to feel safe and they
want to be out and be able to enjoy
themselves Dave Maass Colo managers
Trumbull kitchen in Hartford in
Tennessee people can dine indoors
country star John Rich owns the redneck
Riviera lifts up the things that I do
for a living and they're probably the
worst things you could be doing living
right now in this particular scenario
he's not able to go on tour but is back
in business with his bar and restaurant
in Nashville it was allowed to be fifty
percent open two weeks ago I owned the
bar I own the building the bars in I own
that brand you know I'm a full-blown
business owner of that place so I wanted
to be the guy that actually opened the
door so I went down there did a
temperature check putting my mask on
push the front doors open
what do you know customers started
coming in and you know we followed those
rules like we're supposed to and there
haven't been any incidents and actually
I've got bartenders that are making more
tips than they normally make and I think
that's probably because people realize
what I hit the service industry is taken
how did you do it you had all these
employee
obviously they weren't working for a
little while how did you get everybody
back did you have to get one of those
federal loans so when this first
happened they shut us down March 15th
and of course there was absolute panic
throughout all of our employees we have
about 90 employees at redneck Riviera in
Nashville and we had a meeting me and
the management and my partner's in the
bar and we said you know what we're
going to continue to pay our people
because hopefully this only lasts for a
couple of weeks and if it lasts longer
than that
hopefully the government steps up and
there's some kind of subsidy for
businesses like ours but we're going to
keep continuing to pay our people so we
did continue to pay them even our
bartenders and servers who work mainly
on chips we looked at the month prior to
that so we looked at February and
person-by-person we averaged what they
had made in tips and paid them that
every single week and then about five or
six weeks into it the PPP money was
approved and then that came in so being
able to be partially open and having the
PPP money in there you know at least
it's a stopgap at least you're now not
going backwards but for about six weeks
you know it was full-blown payroll going
out the door with no money coming in but
we feel like that was the right thing to
do by our employees and that's what we
did you talked about getting a mask on
and opening the doors up their employees
are wearing masks right but what about
the customers are you making them do
that so we don't make customers wear
masks
matter of fact the Tennessee rules and
the nashville rules do not require
customers to go into any business to
wear masks it's encouraged that they do
and so when they come in if they if they
don't have a mask we offer them a mask
if they go now don't want a mask
we'll go okay come on in and of course
we make sure everybody's two six feet
apart and and fall follow all the rest
of the rules there's sanitizers
everywhere you know you do things that
go to paper throwaway menus you go to
instead of a instead of a ketchup bottle
or a bottle of Tabasco sauce it's it's
the tear open kind that
you can throw away when you're done you
know little moves like that that limit
how much contact people have with each
other
what about glasses at the bar I mean are
you reusing anything oh man we don't use
a glass and a bar like redneck Riviera
what are you talking about we've done
that we don't even have a dishwasher
there's been talk of restaurants and I
know some states requiring it where they
have to get people's names and phone
numbers or email addresses and contact
tracing so if somebody got sick in the
redneck Riviera you'd be able to contact
everybody else is that something you
have to do no no and nobody's going to
contact tracing me either by the way and
I do think right now we're seeing
examples of certain states certain
cities going to such degrees that I
would call it bordering on communism now
I may take some heat for saying that but
I don't care because we do still have a
constitution we do still have rights and
we are adults and we understand the risk
it's been drilled into our heads now for
ten weeks we know the risks we know our
own health we know where we've been and
who we're around and I believe it's time
for a merit for our American leaders to
trust the American public to abide by
sensible rules but when you start
talking about hey I need to install an
app into your phone so we can trace
everywhere you go the problem with that
is you ever do that you think they're
ever going to take that out of your
phone of course they're not there have
been business owners who have talked
about being afraid of being sued by
someone who might get the virus man
attack with your restaurant what are you
doing about that well so there's
legislation as you know right now to
protect against that so you know I'm
hoping that that legislation gets passed
soon and I think it's coming up for a
vote here very soon I think you have to
do that because the virus is invisible
you know you could have your place
completely completely 100% clean and no
virus in it whatsoever
but it could enter the building on
somebody's clothes
somebody could have it not know it be
asymptomatic and so that's not the
businesses fault
just before we talked to John Rich the
mayor of Nashville Tennessee John Cooper
announced that next week restaurants and
bars that serve food could increase
capacity to three quarters and music
will be back in the Music City live
entertainment can return with no more
than two performers on stage but no one
on the dance floor yet
it means John Rich could sing again
inside the redneck Riviera I could do
that - it's coming Monday so you can bet
your you-know-what I will be going down
there saying to whoever whoever's in the
bar but as far as the big concerts that
that's probably gonna be the last name
that comes back online so touring is not
going to be anything that's going to
happen probably for the rest of years
what I'm hearing and potentially you
know into next year sometime because
problem is how do you socially distance
20,000 big and rich fans yeah I mean
there's no way to do that
you guys did make a song that was very
funny stay home you had some fun with
that in the beginning of this that song
I did enjoy also because if we go on
YouTube I love the empty toilet paper
roll hey John at some point in your
career you're gonna put out a song and
the album art is going to be an empty
roll of toilet paper I would have said
my god have I lost my mind I mean what
happens to me in the future I would have
never believed it they had some fun with
that lyric and it seemed to put a grin
on people's face for a minute yeah and
then you you have to think about how
you're gonna get back out there and and
I know it's not easy I know they're
trying to do concerts what about these
drive up concerts like a movie theater
do you think that could possibly be
something would you be interested in
that sure I mean you know I think at
this point we'd be interested in getting
on a stage wherever a crowd is allowed
to assemble the problem with that is how
many cars can you fit I mean you know
when you do a big and rich show you're
looking
thousands sometimes tens of thousands of
people I mean you know you look in the
parking lots compared to the audience
and the parking lots are stretching out
450 acres you know at some of these big
festivals and things so the whole the
whole touring industry really doesn't
have an answer at this point we're at
this point going crossing our fingers
hoping for a medical breakthrough or a
for a really sped up process with a
viable vaccine where people feel safe
congregating because short of that I
don't know how you do it not you guys
have made it big obviously established
artists they might be able to wait a
little longer this has to be a really
hard on those artists and musicians that
have been trying so hard to make it big
playing little clubs and doing what they
can
it's been tougher they're not making any
money those people no they're not and
you know I think I think when people
think about a country singer or a rock
band or a rapper or what anybody like
that pop singer they think about that
person is just oh well you know they
can't do a concert I'm not really that
empathetic to that but you forget that
along with let's talk about Big and Rich
bus drivers truck drivers light guys
sound guys you go to these they'll band
members tour managers production
managers then you go to the actual
venues that are all shut down you're
talking about caterers security cleanup
crews people that run the bars and
concessions I mean when you extrapolate
that across the entire touring industry
across all genres in America I saw a
number the other day that said it's over
ten million people one way or the other
are losing income from that being shut
down John Rich also has his own show on
Fox Nation called the pursuit starting a
second season with guests including
country star Larry Gatlin and pro
wrestler Jeff Jarrett and he asks the
same question to everyone how has the
right to pursue happiness changed your
life how has the right to pursue
happiness
changed your life and there's a reason
why the show is based on something that
I've said for many years and that is our
country doesn't guarantee is the right
to be happy
it guarantees us the right to pursue
happiness I interview some of the most
incredible people in our country from
inventors to veterans who've started
businesses actors singers songwriters
all kinds of people and I don't care if
they're a liberal conservative or they
don't know what they are I could care
less the show is not anything about
politics it's about inspiring stories
hearing about the grind that people have
gone through chasing their dreams and
pursuing happiness you got to remember
it for people who really chase big
dreams it is difficult and it's a lot of
disappointment but the fact that you get
to do it in the first place unlike
everybody else in the world who don't
have the right to pursue happiness that
fact should in effect make you happy it
hasn't been the happiest time in the
last couple of months across the country
I'll say that no it hasn't but imagine
imagine having kovin 19 your country and
you're in China
imagine having kovat 19 and you're in
Venezuela or Cuba they contact trace
those people the day they're born I mean
you know and you think about it I mean
if we have to keep our perspective as
Americans that yeah it's terrible what's
going on right now but put you in
another country and hit it with kovat
and see how you'd like it you'd be
trying to get back here so fast
you'd break your neck trying to get here
John Rich we look forward to Big and
Rich being back out on the road good
luck with your restaurant of course good
luck with the new show on Fox nation and
thanks so much for joining us
[Music]
it's the Perino and star Walt I'll tell
you what podcast dana perino of the five
and fox news political editor Chris
Stein wall dissect the ins and outs of
national politics subscribe and listen
now by going to a Fox News podcasts
dot-com Rayden review the fox news
rundown on Apple podcasts or wherever
you listen and now some good news with
Tonya J powers creativity has been one
of the things that's helped a lot of
people during the corona virus pandemic
stay at home orders have resulted in an
unexpected side effect for a lot of us
who have been reading books learning new
languages and maybe even finding a new
appreciation for art while some are
learning it others are teaching it
Marshall Ramsey is one of them he's a
two-time Pulitzer Prize finalist and
cartoonist as well as editor-at-large
for Mississippi today since the pandemic
hit he's been doing coloring pages
online for kids to print off and make
their own art at home I asked him how he
got started with it I was pretty sick I
couldn't get tested because I didn't
have a high fever but I had just about
every other bad symptom you could have
and so I was quarantined in my room and
I felt the walls were closing in and
someone had said that you know the best
way to get past that feeling was to give
to other people he featured his dogs Pip
and banjo they were really popular and
and you know brought a lot of joy to
kids and you know who were at home
trying to figure this thing out too then
I talked to my my folks at work at
Mississippi today where I am now the
editor at large and I said hey can I do
coloring sheets on different towns in
Mississippi and allow kids to be able to
take a virtual tour of the state and so
we started doing that too and so now I
do two coloring sheets a day on top of
what everything else I do and those are
really some of the most rewarding things
that I do now we can not only see his
finished product but we can learn how he
does it well people always have enjoyed
watching me draw in the process I
thought why don't we just stick a camera
up over my drawing table and we'll do
drawing lessons and we'll make it for an
hour and I did the first one and got
really good viewership and and it was
really fun because it was interact
interactive
audience starting to build up thank you
for being part of it and spread the word
sherry Lord I can only do so much on the
computer and talk at the same time and
draw got a piece of chewing gum I
probably fall on the floor so we're
gonna give them a little bit of marshal
says it's an escape that a lot of people
need right now it gives them an hour
that they don't have to think about the
pandemic they don't have to think about
the economy they don't have to think
about people screaming on Facebook they
can just kind of get lost and doing the
drawings and when they post the drawings
there's been some of them to be honest
with you are better than mine he says
the experience has given him an
unexpected gift so it's something that
applies to even something deeper than
art you know I mean I can talk about if
they have dreams that they're gonna face
obstacles and this is some of the things
that I did to overcome by obstacles and
so it's been a really positive one hour
and I enjoyed it I really do you can see
Marshalls coloring pages at the
Mississippi today website his drawing
videos on Mississippi today's Facebook
page and you can follow him on Twitter
at Marshall Ramsey Tanya Gioia powers
Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
Brian kill me
what's on your mind well we're caught up
in the pandemic and I understand that
well we'll caught up in the election and
that makes total sense it's coming up in
November I cannot help but think that
while our eyes are off Afghanistan Iraq
and the South China Sea that's exactly
where so much tension is so much
sacrifice is taking place
think about this we're talking about
getting out of Afghanistan but we're
still there we see countless terror
attacks and so many times around the
corner is wildfire we don't think about
that but if you're there you certainly
do in Iraq we have a huge presence we
got irani and militia constantly
rocketing our guys and we just had the
capture of an Isis leader in Iraq where
we have thousands of troops in the South
China Sea it's become clear at least
nine separate incidents of harassment of
our spy planes those who fly often with
lightly armed planes and those on the
Seas naval operations and you think
about the USS Teddy Roosevelt and the
coronavirus and all those who inflicted
with it once one got it it went right
through that ship this is the sacrifice
taking place on a daily basis to keep us
safe to find our enemies overseas so
that we don't find them coming back here
and just when you realize that maybe al
Qaeda is at bay and maybe the Asama bin
Laden the danger and threat died with
him then we find out four months ago the
attack on our military base was none
other than an al Qaeda operative
communicating constantly with Saudi
Arabia and throughout the Middle East
back home he tried to blow up his phone
but he couldn't we found his contacts
and that will relent bright to Islamic
extremism that's the danger and just
keep in mind those keeping the danger
away the men and women in uniform
I'm Brian Kilmeade and that's what I
think
you've been listening to the box news
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes